squeeze really tight it's been four
years since in was able to move his
hands the 23 year old quadriplegic said
he didn't mind being a guinea pig of a
pioneering research program but he never
dreamed he'd be able to do this
ian is the first patient to undergo an
operation that doctors hope could be
used to restore movement to paralyzed
people the world over today was great I
mean to be able to open and close my
hand and do those complex movements that
I haven't been able to do in four years
was great
it took just a tenth of a second for
aliens thoughts to move his hand but the
technology that allowed him to do it -
nearly 10 years to develop
scientists at Iowa State University
implanted a microchip the size of a pea
into IANS brain the chip was connected
to a computer that can decode messages
from the brain the computer then beamed
commands to a sleeve on his forearm that
told his muscles what to do I do believe
there will be a day coming soon when
somebody who has got disability being a
quadriplegic or somebody with a stroke
somebody with any kind of brain injury
can use the power of their mind and by
thinking being able to move their arms
or legs
Ian now coaches lacrosse a sport he used
to enjoy as an active teenager it was a
diving accident that paralyzed him from
the chest down but now he's seen and
felt the potential of a new technology
that could one day prove life-changing
Joe Tidy Sky News